according to the Washington Post
Americans are not getting enough sleep
and it is literally killing us let's
take a look so this is what people are
doing instead of getting enough sleep
these this is for sleepers that get less
than six hours per night and I always
heard that you're supposed to get eight
hours I try to get somewhere around
eight hours normal sleepers get 6 to 11
but this is people that get less than
six they're working that certainly
doesn't surprise right they're commuting
they're socializing tossing and turning
I mean a lot of that way of that but
that's why I same time for that but
that's why everyone's on ambien these
days they're grooming health really
anything's relaxing playing games
watching TV so not all these things are
stress related but you know your body
does actually go through processes when
you're sleeping that it needs to get
ready for the next day and sleep is
important do you guys do you feel you
get enough sleep absolutely not oh god I
get at last night I had such a bad day
yesterday like one of the worst days
from morning till night I actually went
to bed at ten thirty which is I haven't
I can't even remember when I'm gone to
bed that early but normally I get maybe
six and a half hours and it's nowhere
near enough and I walk around exhausted
yeah are you tired right now you seem
very alert and aware or not I feel are
you highly caffeinated not at all really
another had one cup of coffee do I seem
highly caffeinated no but if you're not
getting enough sleep you're nobody a
good night's sleep last night but I know
that one night doesn't make a difference
don't you actually get a sleep deficit
yeah I definitely need a lot more sleep
and I don't get deep enough sleep and
it's def it's debilitating and it's
depressing yeah it really is
debilitating and depressing uh yeah you
know I think an interesting thing about
this chart is that like the people were
only working instead of sleeping because
that's the only thing that no one else
is making you do out of all those other
things Ryan I mean you know you can you
can turn turn down you know socializing
or playing games or commuting I guess
well maybe not community but like you
can't really with working yeah but I
think like I just I just wrapped a show
or just wrapped production on a show
called America cooks with chefs you
should check it out an aura TV good plug
and like last night you know we're
airing episodes right now so last night
of course we were in edit until you know
two in the morning and then feeling
driving home and come back for this you
know it's like I think especially in an
era now where like we're so
interconnected we're
spected to be available all the time
24-7 it's very hard to like stop working
and to stop doing yeah things that we
would normally not do instead of
sleeping yeah so all right so I want to
get to that so I'll skip ahead a little
bit so that thing that we never stop
right how do you manage that in your own
I've been asking every guest now for
weeks because I think everybody's
struggling with this thing you know I
realized for a while that I was starting
in the morning at my phone before I got
out of bed and then I'm looking at it
before I went to sleep and then you're
really you're just putting yourself in
this world costly so I've stopped I've
actually stopped doing that but how did
how do you manage that because that's
what it is work even yeah no it's not
work technically often if you're just on
social media it's still just this
endless thing it's always been a big
challenge for me and and I come from a
family like that my sister and I always
talk about it's like it's like we're
physics experiments and it is a leaf you
are yellow it fills it yeah and it's
like it's so hard for me I actually
sometimes have to block out time to not
do anything yeah and it's very hard for
me to say no would you know we live in a
very competitive society and if I feel
if I don't if I don't keep doing doing
and throwing more [ __ ] against the wall
and it's and it's a fallacy it's a bad
philosophy yeah and sleeping it's not
I'm deeply all i'm doing is depleting
yeah i'm not nourishing i'm happy or at
least on a multivitamin um on your honor
mother bear okay my last one on this do
you think Americans need a siesta you
know many Western European nations have
a siesta I'll do it every now and again
like on a random weekday like it like
four o'clock I just like literally I'll
take like a even if it's a 15 minute
power nap and then I feel great for the
rest of the day now it's against
everything that seemed consumerism and
capitalism really seems to be about like
we can't stop yeah I don't believe the
confirmation for spieler do it but do
Americans need that concept at least
that idea that you can shut down for a
little bit in the day well I would if we
were working in factories like I think
we were a hundred years ago probably
more primarily speaking like I think it
would be a different conversation but I
think a lot of studies have come out
recently that said you know people don't
really even function that well more than
four or five hours at a time you know
doing one specific task
right so you know maybe maybe we need to
change that maybe we'll be more
productive if they felt like they didn't
have to always be just sitting at even
desk waiting for the gate arrived
interesting even the way you answer that
though that people would be more
productive like that right that Matt
Hagan goes you know it's what I can
people have a better quality of life Joe
and I think that it would lead to that
though yeah I think you'd have a better
quality of life and II need to be exact
it's what is this place are ya oh no I'm
just I'm just knowing I know what you're
thinking and let me clarify that than by
saying that I think that you know as if
you're a business owner and you say like
I want people to be productive but if I
give them a better quality of life by
not expecting them to just sit at a desk
and run out of clock maybe in turn that
actually would be better for everybody
involved in like you have a power guys
in your business would be well you know
we can end this with a bit of good news
per ticket for you because we did a
story a couple months ago that your
employer Carlos Slim who I think is the
second richest man in the entire world
and who owns or TV that aunty works at
he he was advocating for a really short
work week yeah he wants to cut the days
and cut the hours that's cuz he doesn't
want to pass there you don't get to be
the second richest guy in the world by
paying overtime will tell you that to
shade no he's great he's wonderful i
don't mean any of that